brenda judd with us again and happy to
have him the national border patrol
council president brandon um a made-up
crisis
uh
and and shifting there's a way mayor
lightfoot was putting it i i think
whatever you whatever your opinion of
governor abbott
he knows about the crisis he knows about
the 2 million plus getting through the
border it's largely along his border um
so the mayor might complain about 50 new
migrants of being dropped off at her
doorstep but i think he's had to deal
with a few more your thoughts
yeah yeah
no when you look at this she's only had
to deal with two buses to this point
that's a hundred people governor abbott
is having to deal with seven thousand
nearly seven thousand people a day
not two hundred seven thousand a day um
and she's complaining about this and
then we also have to um recognize that
these people were going to chicago
anywhere anyway anytime that they get
apprehended we process them they have to
give us an address a verifiable address
and a lot of these people are going to
the chicago area so he's just
facilitating that travel there anyway
but she's now
calling him racist and xenophobic
because he's actually facilitating the
travel to where they were intending to
go anyhow and that is what's the problem
with this what she is saying is cheap
rhetoric rather than actually dealing
with the problem where it where it lies
which is on our borders she's now going
to um
complain about having to deal with a few
hundred people when governor abbott is
dealing with seven thousand people per
day all she has an outsized voice with
this white house all she has to do is
talk to the white house to tell them to
actually do something to get the border
under control which we can do we just
have to have the policies and then maybe
we would get this uh under control well
you raise up a good point because i
always think politics interferes with
this but we have a crisis at the border
it's not a red or blue issue it it's a
very very real issue and it's out of
control and i i just wonder here uh this
is a consistent theme i'm hearing not
only out of the mayor today eric adams
has said much the same thing about all
the buses coming to his city uh you
you've heard you know many arguing
including the homeland security
secretary marcus who has been saying
that it's wreaked havoc that is the
governor's policies on the entire
country well if we stop it there there
are buses going nowhere anywhere so why
don't we get back to that
yeah nil this white house knows exactly
what they need to do to to control
illegal immigration they know exactly
what to do to stop the drugs from
flowing into this country they just
don't do it and what's funny about that
is they've taken a calculated risk you
hear the white house talking about a lot
of different things they'll talk about
foreign policy they'll talk about
inflation they'll talk about all of the
issues that are facing the american
people but they will not talk about
border security because they've taken
the calculated risk they they said that
border security was not going to hurt
them in the midterms and if it doesn't
hurt them in the midterms then we can
continue we can expect to continue to
see this crisis going on if it does hurt
them then they know that it's going to
get continue on into 2024 and they might
do something but if it doesn't hurt
their political fortunes they're going
to continue to let this border be what
it is and they're going to let it be
out of control and american people and
the american people are going to pay for
these policies and that's what's up and
what's odd about it they're you know
they talk about the manufacturing crisis
and all this i know the politics back
and forth but it gets ridiculous i mean
you can see these images you can count
these numbers you you can see you know
all the horror you know on a daily basis
i don't know many beyond fox that that
cover what's happening there but it is
what it is and it's inarguable and and
indisputable it it it's out of control
so when i hear this consistent theme
blaming this so-called manufactured
crisis even though it's a very real
issue when these buses come to their
cities on the part of sanctuary cities
that say all right we're sanctuaries but
we really don't want to work that hard
at it that does seem to be the message
i'm getting from them
and it is and when you look at this when
you talk about what's inhumane it's
inhumane that we're we're approaching
800 deaths on the border prior to this
administration the record was just a
little over 300 now we're approaching
800 deaths when you look at all of the
vulnerable women and children that put
themselves in the hands of these
dangerous cartels that's inhumane it's
these policies that are driving us it's
the magnets the catch and release magnet
that is inviting people to cross our
borders illegally that's inhumane why
isn't mayor lightfoot talking about that
she only talks about this issue when
it's going to directly affect her and
she only does it when it's done in the
light of day this has been happening
over and over and over again thousands
of people have been heading to chicago
they crossed the border illegally and
she doesn't say anything until the
public becomes aware of it and when her
citizens see these buses coming in
that's when she's going to say something
because now she knows that they're going
to be up in armed with with how much
taxpayer money it's going to take to
take care of these people but again
texas has been dealing with this for
over a year and a half thousands of
people every single day now she's
dealing with a couple hundred and and
she's upset that's crazy yeah it's a
fraction of what the governor and
governors before in in texas even in
arizona have been dealing with on a
routine basis welcome to the real world
um brandon thank you very very much hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now